IMPORTANT WITNESS BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS.
AND WE HAVE A LOOK AT THE
EVIDENCE HE SHARED.
>> BRITISH DOCUMENTTARIAN ALEX
HOLDER MET WITH HOUSE
INVESTIGATORS A WHILE AGO.
HE SAID HE COMPLIED WITH A
SUBPOENA AND TURNED OVER HOURS
OF NEVER BEFORE SEEN FOOTAGE OF
TRUMP AND HIS INNER CIRCLE
BEFORE AND AFTER THE JANUARY 6TH
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL.
THIS HOUR WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
YOU A FIRST LOOK AT SOME OF THAT
FOOTAGE THAT WE HAVE OBTAINED
INCLUDING INTERVIEWS WITH TRUMP
TWO MONTHS AFTER THE ATTACK IN
WHICH HE DEFENDED THE CAPITOL
RIOTERS.
AND VIDEO OF THEN VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE REACTING IN REALTIME
TO CONGRESSIONAL CALLS FOR HIM
TO INVOKE THE 25th AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE DONALD TRUMP FROM OFFICE
JUST DAYS AFTER THE
INSURRECTION.
ALSO FEATURED INTERVIEWS WITH
IVANKA TRUMP AND JARED KUSHNER
INCLUDING THE FIRST DAUGHTER
CLAIMING THAT HER FATHER'S GOAL
WAS TO HAVE EVERY VOTE COUNTED,
EVEN AS HE WAS TRYING TO DO THE
EXACT OPPOSITE, TRYING TO
OVERTURN THE E RESULTS OF THE
2020 ELECTION AND THROW OUT
VOTES FROM PEOPLE WHO MIGHT NOT
HAVE VOTED FOR HIM.
ALEX HOLDER HAD EXTENSIVE ACCESS
TO THE 2020 TRUMP CAMPAIGN FOR
THIS DOCUMENTARY THAT'S GOING TO
AIR LATER THIS SUMMER ON THE
STREAMING SERVICE DISCOVERY PLUS
WHICH WE SHOULD KNOW SHARES THE
SAME PARENT COMPANY AS CNN.
DISCOVERY PROVIDED THE CLIPS TO
CNN.
LET'S LOOK NOW AT THE FIRST CLIP
FROM ALEX HOLDER'S DOCUMENTARY.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE PART OF AN
INTERVIEW WITH THEN VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE ON
JANUARY 12TH.
THAT'S THE DAY THEY APPROVED A
RESOLUTION URGING PENCE TO
INVOKE THE 25th AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE DONALD TRUMP FROM THE
OFFICE OF PRESIDENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I JOINED THE SENATE
DEMOCRATIC LEADER IN ALLING ON
THE VICE PRESIDENT TO REMOVE
THIS PRESIDENT BY IMMEDIATELY
INVOKING THE 25th AMENDMENT.
IF THE VICE PRESIDENT AND
CABINET DO NOT, THE CONGRESS MAY
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE POWER OF
IMPEACHMENT.
>> 7:48.
>> THAT'S WHEN I RECEIVED THE
HOUSE MEMBERS GOT IT A WHILE
BACK.
>> YEAH.
EXCELLENT.
UM, TELL ZAC TO PRINT ME OFF A
HARD COPY FOR THE RIDE HOME.
GREAT.
I'M ALWAYS HOPEFUL ABOUT
AMERICA.
>> I ALWAYS BELIEVE AMERICA'S
BEST DAYS ARE YET TO COME, AND I
STILL BELIEVE THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO THAT IS A FIRST LOOK AT AN
EXCERPT FROM ALEX HOLDER'S
DOCUMENTARY, THE DOCUMENTTARIAN
MET WITH THE HOUSE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
DANA, IT IS INTERESTING TO SEE
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
RECEIVE IN REALTIME AN ALERT
THAT THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES WAS DEMANDING
THAT HE INVOKE THE 25th
AMENDMENT ON JANUARY 12TH AND
REMOVE DONALD TRUMP FROM POWER.
>> HE ASKED ABOUT THE TIME.
HE SAW THE TIME STAMP ON THE
EMAIL THAT THE AIDE WAS SHOWING
HIM ON THE EMAIL OR TEXT.
CLEARLY WANTING TO KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT THEY GOT A HEADS UP ABOUT
IT OR WHETHER IT WENT OUT
PUBLICLY.
THAT IS HOW I READ THAT.
BUT ALSO, REMEMBER, THIS WAS
AFTER THE TRAUMA OF JANUARY 6TH.
A COUPLE DAYS LATER.
AND HE IS SO -- HE'S MIKE PENCE.
I MEAN, HE IS SO CALM AND
INTENTIONALLY NOT EMOTING.
MOST TIMES MIKE PENCE IS LIKE
THAT IN PUBLIC AND IN PRIVATE.
THAT IS MIKE PENCE.
BUT IT ALSO STRUCK ME THAT HE IS
SOMEBODY WHO KIND OF GREW UP
AROUND BROADCASTING.
HE WAS IN -- HE WAS A RADIO GUY
BEFORE HE WAS IN POLITICAL
OFFICE.
AND HE WAS KEENLY AWARE THAT THE
CAMERA AND THE MICROPHONE WERE
ON.
>> THIS WAS SIX DAYS AFTER THE
INSURRECTION, SO THAT TRAUMATIC
DAY AND ALSO THE DEATHS THAT
FOLLOWED, BECAUSE REMEMBER, NOT
ONLY DID PEOPLE DIE THAT DAY,
TRUMP SUPPORTERS AND AN OFFICER,
BUT THERE WERE SEVERAL POLICE
OFFICERS WHO COMMITTED DECIDE
EITHER BECAUSE OF THE TRAUMA OR
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY THEY
SUFFERED FURGT ATTACK.
>> ON THE ONE HAND, I WOULD SAY
DON'T PLAY POKER WITH THIS MAN.
ON THE OTHER, CONSIDERING THE
TIMING OF IT, JANUARY 12TH, THAT
HE IS HAVING THIS, IT SEEMS
SURREAL THAT HE IS SO
EMOTIONLESS.
WHAT DOES HE SAY?
YEAH, EXCELLENT.
THE COUGH.
EVERYTHING.
LOOK, OBVIOUSLY THE MUSIC IN THE
DOCUMENTARY ADDS A CERTAIN
EMOTION TO IT, BUT I THINK IT
IS -- SORRY ABOUT THAT -- IT'S
QUITE SOMETHING TO SEE IN
REALTIME WHEN HE KNEW HOW MUCH
PRESSURE HE WAS UNDER.
>> THE THING IS ALSO, WE KNOW
BASED ON WHAT OTHER CABINET TECH
SAYRES THIS SAID, THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE 25th
AMENDMENT WAS HAPPENING BEHIND
THE SCENES.
SO IT -- I THINK IT'S UNLIKELY
THIS --
>> FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
>> BUT CERTAINLY IN THAT TIME
PERIOD AFTER JANUARY 6TH.
SO IT WOULD BE -- I'M CURIOUS TO
KNOW HOW DID THAT COINCIDE?
WERE THERE CONVERSATIONS
PRIVATELY HAPPENING BEHIND THE
SCENES WITH MENACE ABOUT HIS
ROLE IN INVOKING THE 25th
AMENDMENT WITH OTHER CABINET
SECRETARIES INCLUDING SOME WHO
RESIGNED IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME?
PENCE, THOUGH, IN THAT CLIP, AS
DANA SAYS, THAT'S PENCE IN
PUBLIC AND IN PRIVATE.
THE FILM MAKERS SAY IN THAT
CLIP, WHICH IF YOU'RE LISTENING
TO THIS YOU PROBABLY DIDN'T SEE
IT.
HE DECLINED TO TALK ABOUT
JANUARY 6TH.
THAT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT WHERE HIS
HEAD WAS AT IN THOSE DAYS AFTER
THE ATTACK.
EVEN AFTER ALL THAT HE
EXPERIENCED, HE STILL WASN'T
WILLING TO GO THERE, TO EVEN BE
IN A POSITION TO CRITICIZE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> IT'S VISUAL EVIDENCE OF THE
STRAIGHT JACKET MIKE PENCE PUT
HIMSELF IN FOR THE ENTIRE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
TRYING TO STAY CALM, TRYING TO
USE HIS TALKING POINTS I BELIEVE
THE BEST OF AMERICA, BEST DAYS
ARE AHEAD.
BECAUSE HE'S SURROUNDED BY CHAOS
FROM DAY ONE, AND TO ABBIE'S
POINT, HE WON'T TALK ABOUT
JANUARY 6TH th.
NOW MIKE PENCE IS MADE A CLEAR
BREAK FROM TRUMP ON THAT DAY.
EVEN THEN HE WAS NOT SURE WHAT
IS IN MY BEST POLITICAL
INTEREST, NOT GOING TO --
>> THIS IS THE LETTER PENCE
WROTE TO SPEAKER PELOSI IN WHICH
HE SAYS NO, I'M NOT GOING TO
INVOKE THE 25th AMENDMENT.
HE SAYS, LAST WEEK I DID NOT
YIELD TO PRESSURE TO EXERT POWER
BEYOND MY CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY TO DETERMINE THE
OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION, AND I
WILL NOT NOW YIELD TO EFFORTS TO
PLAY POLITICAL GAMES AT A TIME
SO SERIOUS IN THE LIFE OF OUR
NATION.
HE SAYS THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S ENERGY IS
DIRECTED TO ENSURING AN ORDERLY
TRANSITION, WHICH MIGHT BE TRUE
FOR HIM BUT NOT FOR A LOT OF
OTHER PEOPLE INCLUDING DONALD
TRUMP.
HE SAID I URGE YOU AND MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS TO STOP DOING THINGS
THAT WOULD INFLAME THE DIVIDES.
HE WAS LIKE I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS.
BUT LET'S TAKE A LOOK NOW AT
ANOTHER PORTION OF THIS
DOCUMENTARY.
IT'S AN INTERVIEW WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
THIS IS AFTER THE INSURRECTION
N. THIS IS IN MARCH OF 2021.
AT HIS FLORIDA HOME, MAR-A-LAGO.
>> CAN WE TALK FOR A MINUTE
ABOUT JANUARY 6TH?
>> YEAH.
WELL, IT WAS A SAD DAY, BUT IT
WAS A DAY WHERE THERE WAS GREAT
ANGER IN OUR COUNTRY.
PEOPLE WENT TO WASHINGTON
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THEY WERE
ANGRY WITH AN ELECTION THAT THEY
THINK WAS RIGGED.
A VERY SMALL PORTION, AS YOU
KNOW, WENT DOWN TO THE CAPITOL,
AND THEN A VERY SMALL PORTION OF
THEM WENT IN.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THEY WERE
ANGRY FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE ELECTION.
BECAUSE THEY'RE SMART, AND THEY
SAY AND THEY SAW WHAT HAPPENED,
AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS A
BIG PART OF WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH.
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY
RESTRAINED.
HE'S JUSTIFYING THE CRIMINALITY
AND THE INSURRECTIONISTS.
HE'S DOWN PLAYING WHAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO.
THEY WERE NOT JUST EXPRESS
ANGER.
THERE WERE THERE TO STOP GIVING
THE PRESIDENCY.
>> HE WAS TALKING AS IF IT JUST
HAPPENED IN A PLACE FAR AWAY
FROM ANYTHING THAT HE DID OR
SAID OR NOW THAT WE ARE SEEING,
TRIED TO COORDINATE WITH THE
PEOPLE AROUND HIM.
THEY DIDN'T JUST GET ANGRY.
HE MADE THEM ANGRY BY TELLING
THEM LIES.
AND HE'S NOT SEPARATED FROM
THAT.
EVEN THOUGH HE'S TRYING TO
SEPARATE HIMSELF.
THAT IS CLASSIC DONALD TRUMP.
HE KNOWS BECAUSE HE DID THIS HIS
ENTIRE LIFE, IF YOU SAY
SOMETHING ENOUGH TIMES, AND IF
YOU SELL WHATEVER YOU'RE TRYING
TO SELL, WHETHER IT'S AN IDEA OR
A PRODUCT, ENOUGH TIMES THE SAME
WAY, YOU CAN GET PEOPLE TO SIGN
ON.
>> LET'S BE HONEST.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THAT THERE WAS
NOT ONE WORD OF CONDEMNATION
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH THAT CAME OUT OF HIS
MOUTH AT THAT TIME.
BUT IT'S ALSO NOTABLE THAT THAT
POSITION THAT TRUMP HAD THEN IN
THE MONTHS AFTER JANUARY 6TH IS
ACTUALLY THE POSITION THAT HAS
BEEN ADOPTED BY MANY REPUBLICANS
TODAY.
MANY LAWMAKERS ON CAPITOL HILL,
WHICH IS TO SAY OH, IT WAS JUST
A FEW PEOPLE.
IGNORING TOTALLY THE VIOLENCE
AND THE INTENT HERE WHICH WAS TO
STOP THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER.
THIS IS A PORTRAIT OF A FORMER
PRESIDENT WHO IS STILL
CULTIVATING WHAT HE DESCRIBED AS
ANGER ON THAT DAY.
AND THAT, I THINK, IS WHAT THE
COMMITTEE AS WE'RE GOING THROUGH
THE HEARINGS, WANTS TO REITERATE
TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
IT'S WHAT JUDGE LUTTIG SAID.
THE CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER FOR
THE FUTU